both football players are defined
President Trump after he told them not
to protest during the national anthem
mr. Trump's criticism led to sidelines
demonstrations yesterday at stadiums
across the country more than 200 players
kneeled locked arms or sat out Sunday's
pregame ritual the president said on
Friday that the protest is quote total
disrespect of our heritage wouldn't you
love to see one of these NFL owners when
somebody disrespects our flag to say get
that son of a gun that field right now
out he's fired
New England Patriots owner Bob Kraft who
gave Mr Trumper Super Bowl ring and
contributed to his campaign says he was
deeply disappointed by the president's
comments Kraft said in a statement
our players are intelligent thoughtful
and cared deeply about our community and
I support the right to peacefully affect
social change DeMarco Morgan is at
MetLife Stadium in New Jersey home of
the New York Giants and the Jets DeMarco
good morning good morning the New York
Jets acting owner Christopher Johnson
linked arms with his players during the
game yesterday here at the stadium his
brother as the president's ambassador to
England and it seems as if the
president's words only reignited the
protest rather than silence Sunday's
final NFL matchup between the Washington
Redskins and Oakland Raiders was played
minutes from the White House during the
anthem players joined arms sat or knelt
even Redskins owner Dan Snyder a trump
supporter joined in Redskins quarterback
Josh Norman
nobody Shahid conned the league's only
Muslim owner and a trump supporter
locked arms with his team the
Jacksonville Jaguars dozens of Jaguars
and Baltimore Ravens players took a knee
we just got our first glimpse of what
figures to be an eye-opening day in the
NFL
several Miami Dolphins wore shirts
supporting Colin Kaepernick the ex 49er
quarterback who began the protests last
year to draw attention to racism and
police brutality on Sunday the Tennessee
Titans and most of the pittsburgh
steelers stayed off the field during the
anthem pittsburgh lineman Alejandro
Villanueva a former Army Ranger stood
alone Steelers coach Mike Tomlin we're
not going to be disrespectful in the
anthem so they chose not to participate
but at the same time many of them we're
not going to accept the words of the
president the Seattle Seahawks also
stayed off the field player said in a
statement quote we will not stand for
the injustice that has plagued people of
color in this country while some fans
booed the players to anthem singers in
Nashville and in Detroit knelt in
solidarity
[Applause]
what many NFL owners have been in
support of their players there are many
NASCAR executives that do not want their
employees to protest the anthem the
owner of Richard Petty said quote
anybody that don't stand up for the
anthem ought to be out of the country
here yet charlie
DeMarco thanks